waking up early world seems so quiet
rest of your family and friends are
sleeping but you're getting out of bed
washing your face and sitting on your
desk to start your day early to get that
work done to do that exercise achieving
it all a few hours before everyone else
wakes up this video is brought to you by
Squarespace I've always been a morning
person and been waking up between three
to four a.m since I can remember
apparently I'm a fourth year medical
student and when I first started med
school I had a lecture by a neurology
Professor about circadian rhythms which
means your biological body clock that
lecture had seven to eight slides but
for you I pulled out the key information
and also added some tips from my
personal experience as an extreme early
bird everyone is unique and have
different biological clocks this chart
that I stole from the professor shows
that there are people with various
biological clocks in our world starting
from extreme morning people like myself
to extreme night people so people who
tend to stay up until late at night or
even until early morning it's a whole
Spectrum you must have heard Apple CEO
Michelle Obama the rock all of those
successful celebrities wake up before
5am waking up early is often portrayed
as being productive in the media
contrary to Common belief being an early
bird doesn't automatically make you more
productive than night owls and vice
versa there has been many occasions
especially on holidays where I still
wake up at 3am but binge to watch my
favorite Netflix show which is
questionably a productive activity so
it's about how you spend your time
whether it's an early morning or late at
night but for me one of the biggest
advantages of waking up early is that
there are less distractions in early
hours of the day which makes it ideal
for deep focus work it's described by
Newport as state of distraction free
concentration when your brain works at
its maximum potential if you want to
become more of a morning person you can
train your body clock and here is how I
wake up at 3am naturally without an
alarm firstly go to bed early it sounds
bad basic but it is essential let's ask
my flatmates about my sleep schedule
who's been witnessing me wake up and go
to sleep throughout the year here I am
with Clara as known as flat me number
one what so I am so made everyone's
actual flight main number one how was my
sweet schedule like
very odd is really weird only time with
cm is if I'm up in the morning for my
breakfast and that's when she has her
lunch we barely see you because you're
asleep so early you could just hang out
in the mornings do you know what time I
wake up and go to sleep oh
um I think you wake up at like around
4am and about 6 p.m I think you go to
bed even though my flatmates exaggerated
it but I still go to bed early around
half past seven because getting enough
sleep is the key to waking up feeling
refreshed for me enough sleep means
seven and a half hours of sleep but this
can change from person to person and it
also differs by age these are the hours
of sleep each age group need according
to Health Service of the UK that's why
you really want to avoid sacrificing
sleep to become an early riser because
it will catch up with you you can cut
your sleep short to wake up early for a
couple of days but then sleep
deprivation will cause you poor
concentration anxiety tiredness during
the day and it won't be a sleep rooting
you can maintain if earlier Rising means
cutting sleep don't do do it I have to
fall asleep early using light therapy if
you're not used to sleeping early once
you're in bed falling asleep can be
difficult reducing blue light exposure
before bed is helpful studies found that
warmer colored lights increase melatonin
production which is the sleep hormone of
the body the hormone which makes you
more sleepy to encourage my body to
sleep I make my LED lights warmer
colored so yellow orange and red tones
if you don't have access to LED lights
then you can just make your room darker
by dimming your lights also less
exposure to Bright Lights by reducing
your screen time on your phone or on
your laptop as you start winding down
should help as well I choose to just not
bring my phone into my bed so I don't
scroll on Tick Tock and Instagram
aimlessly whilst I'm supposed to sleep
you can also make use of lights when you
wake up in the morning this is actually
part of a treatment called light therapy
in medicine and it's used in patients
with Sleep Disorders you can create
slight therapy at home for cheap by just
doing the opposite of what you do in the
evening so when you first wake up in the
morning make your lights cooler colored
light blue or cool white or you could
just make your room brighter by turning
on your lights and it helps you feel
more energized and alert during the day
morning routines and waking up with a
plan having a goal and a plan motivates
you and makes it easy to get up so
understand why you want to wake up early
in the first place for example because
you want to get ahead of your revision
before school or exercise before work or
just have time to meditate and pray
before leaving home having a morning
routine sets the tone for the day and it
gives a sense of structure and purpose
which can help improve overall
productivity of your day and when you're
being consistent with your morning
routine your body becomes used to the
schedule and helps you naturally wake up
at the same time each day for me early
morning is the time where I can focus
and learn the best so I prioritize
getting as much studying done as
possible if you want to see my 3am
morning routine you can watch it here
before we continue with the rest of the
video I want to present you squares face
it's a platform where you can do website
designs for an online store or a Blog I
wouldn't even know where to begin with
building a website on my own but they
make it so simple as they have so many
beautiful fully customizable templates
and this is the website I created on
training your circadian rhythm
Squarespace is there to support you
throughout your journey of building a
successful brand starting from seamless
domain registration to creating a logo
for your business and they have 24 7
customer support if you needed anything
so if you want to create your own site
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com silly hard to save 10 of
your first purchase of a website or
domain exercise it's well known that
exercise has lots of benefits and one of
them is that it increases Sleep Quality
and helps you fall asleep faster
exercise affects your body clock by
increasing body temperature and by
producing Adrenaline Rush which makes
you more awake and alert that's always
recommended to exercise in the morning
or early afternoon avoid doing high
intensity exercise within an hour of
bedtime as it can keep you up at night
for longer lasting results move your
body clock slowly so Advance your
bedtime a bit earlier each night until
the desired bedtime is reached for
example go to bed at midnight one night
then 11 45 the next then 11 30 the
following night and so on doing this
Progressive change in your sleep routine
will help your body adapt more easily
consistency keeping your night routine
consistent and following bedtime rituals
are useful for example simple stuff like
brushing your teeth putting on your
pajamas whatever you usually do before
going to bed do a bit earlier this
reinforces in your mind that it is
bedtime diets eating late at night or
too close to bedtime can keep you awake
especially if it's a big meal your body
will be focused on digesting the food
rather than relaxing and preparing for
sleep I usually eat my last meal of the
day at least three hours before bed
alsoever avoiding caffeine and sugary
food in the evening improves quality of
sleep as well so why do I wake up early
many people in my comments seem worried
because I wake up at 3am every day but
I've been living like this for over 20
years now I'm naturally a morning person
my default is to wake up early I'm
embracing what works best for me and my
schedule and I hope you do the same
whether it means waking up late or early
if you want to find out about your body
clock you can check out the
questionnaire I put in the description I
linked the exact questionnaire the
neurologist asked us to do before the
lecture oh wait I need to think what I
have to say first okay what do I want to
say whatever you want to say love they